what up reject nation we got ourselves
some new rock stars the thor love and
thunder trailer easter egg breakdown
let's hop into this leave a like check
out our thor love and thunder trailer
reaction and also check out coy janja's
first episode of uh koi's comic corner
appreciate all the love he's been
getting let's get into it
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
latest trailer for thor love and thunder
which finally reveals the face of the
villain gore the god butcher yeah
like me he looks sick it is time for i
will flick you all the details you
missed and not just because this is the
second marvel trailer in one week to
lead with ass though we actually just go
friend by frame through that ass shot
because there are some interesting
details there not the details you think
all the details you think but also more
details than anything i want the details
that i'm thinking of okay we open with
this same shot of thor meditating
beneath this wisdom tree that we saw in
the last trailer what a key difference
they've now added two figures hiking up
to thor from behind ah a good catch
perhaps peter quill does look like pratt
silhouette there and then i would say
either nebula or mantis but this woman
doesn't exactly match their silhouettes
so maybe there's green maybe jane maybe
gamora will this movie finally reunite
variant gamora with the rest of the
guardians we can actually see that same
tree behind korg as he's regaling the
kids maybe telling the kids hey don't
bother uncle thor right now he's getting
some alone time now this blue skinned
race is actually the same tribe that the
guardians fight alongside in the other
shots i'm thinking they're the zatoan
tribe of the planet centauri 4 the same
tribe as yondu which is why the
guardians feel such a kinship with this
tribe wanting to defend yondu's home
planet so this planet is yondu's home
world of centauri 4 that would make
these other planets and stars in the sky
part of the alpha centauri system alpha
centauri being the largest sun in the
sky and it's interesting that we can see
so many of these planets
because it could be how this movie
visually conveys my theory that
centauri's neighboring planet of century
6 referenced in eternals as a past
planet that the eternals helped destroy
to birth the celestial could get
referenced in this movie we might even
see the ruins of that planet in the sky
and that could be the whole world of
gore the reason why he hates all gods
now you know that would be fascinating
if that is true that these are the
yondu's race and then so you're picking
up from where we left off with the
guardians at least in terms of volume
two it does make me hope that with the
guardians being here because i know with
like infinity war at least i believe
james gunn was consulted on the writing
for them i am hoping that you know take
away td oscar-winning writer let's not
get ahead of ourselves he still might
need some of that james gunn voice in
those characters so i'm hoping that
james gunn was still involved in some
way that's a dream collab right there or
to battle of the egos oh god might have
the big studio system never we see thor
powering up stormbreaker we actually see
him coming down on whoever these raiders
are in the final shot of the trailer
then thor pops the collar of his leather
vest on the benatar while the other
guardians turn to look actually looks
like he may have borrowed some of these
clothes from peter quill like this looks
like it used to be quill's red jacket
but now with the sleeves removed because
i yeah there's no way those tree trunks
are going to fit in sleeves you're
saying he might have removed the arms
and then added the diamond arrow
pointing up
on the back
absolutely thor's getting into
customization and sewing and studying
and all sorts of things man that's how
you retreat that's how you treat
yourself actually the shirt he's wearing
looks like an artistic display of the
nine realms spread out across the israel
which of course is the asgardian world's
tree and this whole tank and jesus look
looks a lot like kurt russell's look in
big trouble little china kurt russell of
course playing peter quill's father of
the ego some new shots of new asgard and
tonsburg norway and it stayed as a
tourist attraction now in addition to
the cruise liners one of them having the
face of volstag members of the warriors
three who died in ragnarok we can also
see a golf course now i'm not sure if
these greens are on the same field where
helle broke my near and where odin died
if so it's kind of sad for tourism to
carpet over that site but actually in
the middle of that green is some figure
that might be just a golfer with this
caddy or might be that pedestal that
contains the broken shards of mjolnir
those shards unable to be lifted and
moved and maybe now that's thor just
sitting on a monument oh that would make
it so much more rewarding if they set it
up that way i didn't even think about
that the broken pieces of male north you
can't even move that i thought it'd have
to be like a complete hammer that's how
i always viewed it if it's immovable but
if that would be uh kind of poetic in
some way yeah and then it would lead to
a big surprise moment when it shows back
up all kitsune you know yeah big
surprise that was revealed in the
trailer
yeah
remove that bit of catharsis from the
actual movie experience and thursday on
that pile of milner that's gonna really
hurt his ass that fine ass centaur uses
stormbreaker to change into his
asgardian leathers so if those were
beater coils closed i guess they're gone
now we can see cord reigning thor's
goats let's give this a shot tangrity
and tanyos i don't know but they
translate to teeth bearers slash teeth
snarler and then teeth grinder these
goats are famously thor's steeds from
norse mythology but like in the shot of
this from the first trailer this one
also is just framed in a weird way to
make me think that there is a third
character who has been digitally removed
from the trailer footage so sure it
could be a beta ray bill one of the
versions of the comics he's gotta make
it into the live action mcu at some
point so i'm praying that's the case but
behind them now in this shot you can see
more of those blue skin ceterians so
this still would be that same planet and
if that white shot was showing gamora
she would be another surprise character
that they might want to leave out of the
trailer vader ray bill gamora someone
else let me know who you think is
actually here in the comments below all
right you know i said i feel like if
you're gonna have gamora that should be
reserved for guardians of the galaxy vol
3. that's like such a guardian specific
story you know yeah and catharsis would
serve them yeah a thousand percent we're
on the same page here
where's the day rarely do we ever agree
then more shots of thor's mr incredible
style workout routine battle ropes with
these chains and a giant skeleton i'm
still wondering if it could be one of
the passcodes that gore has captured and
tortured or once again wears the trucker
hat that previously had mightiest
avengers on it then now he sharpied over
it that instead of mightiest it's
strongest and then avengers is now just
avenger he crossed out the x i like that
height but we're being the strongest
avenger a recurring joke that's been in
all these movies meanwhile his whole
book is modeled on vincent d'onofrio's
character in adventures of babysitting
when that girl thought he was thor but
another one of his fitness goals was to
toe the entire benatar the fact that
he's able to take any steps at all is
pretty impressive i feel like this
session is going to end with quill just
flooring it and yanking thor off playing
it so they could suddenly hit the brakes
and then he like smacks up against the
back window this time
all right on to the next clip
and after all that
he reclaimed his title
as the one and only thor
oh spook too soon
jane
that's got to be a different thor man
he's fighting off these dark monsters
who are attacking the town field
these may be the black berserkers who
are gore's minions from the comics whom
he summons with his sword really
extensions of himself since all black
was the weapon of the symbiote deity of
no in the comics the black berserkers
aren't away kindred of the symbiotes
which yes remain sony properties but
marvel doesn't have to explicitly go
into the sword's symbiote backstory in
this movie it is nice to see all the
other towns people actively fighting off
the berserkers as well it's not just the
asgard protectors of the irony are i in
her iron jar i in her jar i don't know
we are seeing plain close civilians
picking up pipes and stuff and beating
them down now thor tries to summon
mjolnir but it hovers inches from his
fingers and luke lightsabers from kylo
to rey jane foster is the mighty thor
from jason aaron's comic run in which
jane uses mjolnir to power up into thor
to escape her cancer treatments this
trailer may later hinted why jane is
carrying mule near i'll get to that in a
bit right here there is some odd editing
going on because in the reaction shot
thor is suddenly now sitted up in his
brighter golden armor in his helmet as
opposed to his leather armor that he was
wearing before so really we're seeing
two moments stitched together maybe one
earlier in the battle and then one at
the end of the battle where the two
finally step up to each other his arm is
all different there's something goofy
about the framing here like
yeah
on the green screen as if they may be
masking something here like i'm just
gonna be surprised if this is exactly
how it looks in the theatrical version
of the movie so why the armor upgrade
why are all the characters wearing armor
upgrades i think it may be jane as the
mighty thor wielding mjolnir that causes
all the asgardians to suit up in this
new badass look like jane signals the
new changing to the guard i guess the
part that's weird to me about it if it
is just two different moments stitched
together both shots seem like they're
the first time he's seeing jane as
mighty thor so that's why i think some
people i've been thinking that maybe
this there's two thor's there
multiversal variants crossover because
milner is coming to him he's like
and then he watches it get retracted
back to her that lines up and then it
cuts to the other shot we're just going
jay like shocked to see her yeah i don't
know why why else you would be doing
that again he's got a short-term memory
thing in this movie
they're not revealing yet so jane is
riding a pegasus the same kind of steed
valkyrie road in in-game she's driving
into this weird chamber see two shots of
it here but there's a wider shot later
in the trailer that gives us a big shot
oh [ __ ]
oh
oh
yes
that's the living tribunal the clearest
one to the far right is the living
tribute
representing equity necessity and
revenge they just made a cameo in
multiverse madness the first alternate
dimension that american chavez and
strange tumbled through but in that case
all three bases were separated from each
other maybe a way of showing that we
were on a different dimensional plane
there and of course
living tribunal statues showed up
severed in the void
at the time i speculated could that have
been a reality where the living tribunal
was overthrown maybe by someone like
gore the god butcher the fact that the
lady
yes that's what i just noticed
the watcher definitely the character
voiced by jeffrey wright and what if the
watchers being another cosmic entity
that just oversees observes the
multiverse it's not supposed to
interfere but then if you slide to the
left there is a hooded figure a skull
presumably lady death who in the comics
thanos did all of his dirty stuff for
then on the left in the far back there
is a bald feminine figure who looks a
lot like infinity the sister to eternity
and then between them
aka he who waits an offspring of
eternity who's associated with the
concept of time so what is this place
well jane entered this through a glowing
orange rift suggesting that it's not
accessible through any physical means
i'm wondering if this could be a shrine
into the higher tier of cosmic beings
above the god tier perhaps an mcu
version of those who sit above in shadow
the gods to the gods who oversee the
asgardians and lend mjolnir its power
perhaps it was these figures who
selected jane to wield mjolnir because
notice it is only here where she is
channeling the lightning and the thunder
to power the hammer these overseers of
the multiverse may have taken mercy on
jane foster for her cancer and seen some
cosmic imbalance with mjolnir being
destroyed selecting jane as the all-time
keeper of thor's heart as the rightful
wielder for this particular battle and i
say this particular because i don't know
if the plan is to ultimately have jane
foster be the permanent thor going
forward that wasn't the case ultimately
in the mighty thor comic run i think
ultimately by the end of this movie
mjolnir may be destroyed once more and
like beta raid bill maybe wielding
stormbreaker whoa that is i did what you
said yeah the first time i watched this
trip
yeah the living tribunal brought up
again and then the watcher i didn't
really think this would have much to do
with like multiverse connections and
maybe it's going to be like another
multiverse of madness situation where
it's just the statues are there we're
not really going to explore it but we
are crossing different types of gods
into this one as well and then to have
lady death in there a character a lot
suspected might be also an infinity war
i don't know the way people hoped
multiverse and madness could be the game
changer maybe this will be the game
changer in a way it could be i mean
because this phase seems to keep setting
up different powers that be in different
god figures like eric pointed out too
about maybe them building up to
uh what is it the the the higher up the
watchers in the shadows or whatever part
of you thinks i'm gonna remember what he
just said five seconds you know
maybe you read some bit of source
material i didn't know two of the
statues he was talking about either way
this being a movie about a god and the
realm of other gods i could see it being
a surprise actually very sort of
earth-shattering installment for the
overall mcu especially if we do go above
to a tier of gods where maybe they can
intervene and demonstrate some of their
actual power because so much of the gods
we've seen in this phase have all been
about we can't intervene yeah you know
and maybe there's a reason for that well
when you got a god killer intervening
now another way to interpret this is you
could connect it to the temple art of
morag back in guardians of galaxy vol 1.
that art depicted four figures death
infinity eternity and entropy now we
don't know if these five in this chamber
are the only statues in this room there
could be more out of frame but either
way i think we are looking at the
reigning hierarchy of cosmic authorities
in the mcu you have humans on one tier
above them you have asgardians they
report to zeus zeus and his tear
literally being larger gods 10 feet tall
who reign over the pantheon of gods of
olympus and then all of those gods
report to this ultimate cosmic tear
including the living tribunal death uatu
eon and infinity now moving on thor says
eight years seven months and six days
since he and jane broke up now thor
ragnarok made it sound like he and
jane's breakup was recent so eight years
seven months after that would track with
this movie keeping up with the mcu
present day of 2025. but jane thinking
in three to four years is not her losing
track or not caring about thor because
remember jane was blipped her face
showed up on these streets and the
official screenplay confirmed that jane
foster was one of the blip victims now
then again that screenplay also
confirmed wong dusted as well despite
spider-man no way home ignoring that
making wong's source for supreme while
strange was blitzed but that would
hardly be the first mcu plot hole ever
so if jane flipped for her it would only
feel like three or four years instead of
eight and a half maybe they'll introduce
some type of concept in there because
there's always been concepts uh theories
about some type of radiation occurring
with the blip and maybe that's something
that activates the cancer within jane oh
that would be a horrible cosmic irony i
know radiation causes it all
instead of taking it away i mean i've
always thought that maybe some of the
ether is left over in her body so maybe
some type of
do you know words yeah smash combo
conversion boom
stuff to get her cancer we've just gotta
we just gotta give her cancer
same cancer the anchor sam's worth makes
i think my favorite vocalization he has
ever made
[Music]
and valkyrie being converted
in
a dream about that
i just love all these shots of
valkyrie's armor that bold black and
silver color with this norse logo she's
looking for black and silver makes her
visually at least a purple silver black
silver final battle this movie a
desaturated one with gore and we love
that too the color coming back from the
bolt
so this is my vow
oh god shall die
so we hear christian bale as gore the
godbutcher this interesting shot though
of a piece of rock floating toward a
rift in space toward a lonely planet on
the other side maybe earth maybe
someplace else on that rock surface is a
kind of caged structure it actually
looks like the red cape of thor inside
of it this might be how gore navigates
from place to place then the hilt of all
black the necker sword or whatever
they're gonna call this sword in this
movie lifts into gore's hand and then
gore reveals himself pushing out of a
snaking tangle of inky vines and
lowering his hood to show his scarred
face white robes stained with blood from
his mouth and his open wounds it seems
like we only ever see gore in black and
white except for his eyes they
especially boosted the contrast in this
shot giving it enormous quality like we
saw on frank miller and robert gardner
yeah
this upped contrast just really sharpens
all the scars and the lines of his face
giving him a withered look making him
look both very strong but also dead
inside like the most jacked legs you've
ever seen a man who has lost everything
has nothing to lose vengeance incarnate
now gore in the comments my skin is
eggshell white
but i personally am thankful they let
christian bale keep his nose it looks so
much like voldemort voldemort is
supposed to have a snake nose in the
books i know he does it's just rape
vines look stupid in those movies they
tried to make it work it did not work
and it would have been better if they
just let replies keep his damn nose
christian bale has a cool scary angular
base and they are smart not to cover it
up
freaking looks like nosferatu man
justice for bale's nose i am curious to
know if christian bale stayed in
character on set the whole time and
ruined the fun for everyone on taiko
ytd's comedy set
yep yep he threatened several gods in
the process people were just like
messing with him just shouting at the
sky you and me were done
oh walking around up in the sky in the
middle of the [ __ ] scene
i want to see christian bale on this one
so what do you think oh it's set for
this movie yeah i want the bts on this
please address me score
now the vines that gore pushes through
may actually be a form of his sword that
black and white world could actually be
a pocket realm that is created by all
black now of course one of gore's
victims is falagar the behemoth a frame
taken directly by eastside remakes
amazing artwork in jason aaron's
storyline and can we use this
opportunity to bag marvel studios stop
just giving these comics writers and
artists special thanks in the credits of
the movie pay them as much as you're
paying the directors especially if
you're lifting the frame and putting
directly in the marketing of the movie
which is directly going to lead
make it right pay your artists onto the
next clip nah that's dumb yeah you know
five people buy that comic when the
movie comes out so that'll make up for
it
it's just my first time right you should
pay the artist so thor pops stormbreaker
into the goat boat which is what i'm
going to call it now and that boat
leaves a gumbo awake stormbreaker has
the power of the bifrost the rainbow
bridge jane and valkyrie help thor fight
off some olympian guards and here and
actually you can see even more clearly
in that butt shot you can see thor has
some back tattoos it looks like he inked
loki's helmet and a square shape that i
think might be mjolnir oh cool
everything he has lost onto his back so
that might also include odin his mother
frigga gene tony stark black widow all
the things he has lost so why
he's gonna have sleeves by the end when
he showed up at falagar's crime scene
thor could have been falsely accused for
killing these gods as olympus may think
only thor has the might to take down so
many of them then an epic shot of gore
plunging his sword clutching the blade
into a planet especially if the sword's
giving off electricity they're going to
kill falagar i am wondering if gore is
doing this to try to kill a celestial
that might be gestating in
[Music]
me it's
wait a second isn't
the all black connected to the planet
nowhere in some way i believe that's
correct yeah and then it's connected to
the planet nowhere and nowhere was also
seen in guardians of the galaxy
as a mining colony i believe it's about
something what to do with
this symbiotic quality
of tire remember this let's do it the
symbiotic
quality of the all black trying to like
go back to its original i was thinking
trying to crawl back to the depths from
whence it came yeah while it's
attempting well it's attached to the
neck resort with gore it's easy to get
caught doing too much this is the case
that thor being captured this is also
kind of repetitive of what happened to
dr strange multiverse and madness
getting captured by a high-level
authority being accused of something he
hasn't done oh yeah and then gore is
gonna break right in and murder zeus and
everybody honestly
thor and valkyrie fight gore on this
broken surface that he shattered before
the photography just looks incredible it
looks as though thor and valkyrie are in
the process of being desaturated during
this fight like
draining the color in the light force
from the whole world you can see this
especially as valkyrie parries gore
using one of zeus's lightning bolts like
the rest of her body is desaturated but
the color seems to be coming from that
bolt sounds like zeus is going to die or
emits a blast from stormbreaker other
than the bolts the rest of the shot has
the color draining from it so why is
valkyrie using zeus's bolt maybe zeus
has been killed and the ranking power of
olympus has temporarily passed down to
her during this crisis it just seems
like as this final battle wages on all
of the color is going to be drained
until we are in complete black and white
the stylistic choice that we previously
have only seen in the mcu in things like
wanda vision and the first captain
america film in order to invoke a
deliberately nostalgic quality but here
it looks like the color changing is a
direct consequence of factors within the
scene on to the last clip let's see who
you are i take off your disguise
and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it
should we help him mean eventually grape
so russell crowe as zeus sounds like
he's committing to a greek accent good
for you russell and i gotta look at that
which uh yeah is becoming a bit of an
mcu inside innuendo because remember
ant-man and in-game said flick me
captain as he stuck his butt out because
if you spell out flick me in a comic
sans word bubble in all caps
merge together to look like you so you
know the line you flick too hard damn it
you get the idea and i assume thor will
not be blurred out yes
zeus flicks you know zeus flips faints
aside from zeus but including the guys
and that bearded harpist meanwhile jane
andre and korg wear hooded cloaks while
they sit in stands i presume they're
currently disguised not that great of
disguises but in the officials photo
that revealed bostep they were not
wearing those cloaks seated behind them
here is a god with larger feet
suggesting that many of the gods seated
around them may have immense forms ten
feet tall the way towerets and amit were
in moon knight now we can't really see
boston too well here maybe we'll see her
better than the imax aspect ratio
version of this trailer but you can see
from her feline ears she's turning her
head a bit taking it in now bastet and
bost are both names referring to the
egyptian cat goddess but also bost is
the wakandan panther deity this movie
may suggest the mythologies of black
panther and moon knight and thor are all
linked part of the same mythological
system as moon knight started to do by
confirming the ancestral plane it's just
one of many mcu advertisements exactly
with the moon knight maybe bost and
bastet are the same entity maybe black
panther is considered an avatar of bost
and since but shangha consumed that
heart-shaped urban met boston 10000 bc
really wakanda mythology was the first
mythology on the planet earth in the mcu
implying that may have influenced all
the rest see all these people who are
acting like marvel phase four hasn't
been connected or it's not being clear
it's like there's just too much
happening
to show it they're just not necessarily
obviously going look at these details
feeding directly and you know it's a big
playing field and each piece gives more
flesh to it i know he's theorizing right
now but it also sounds like
he's more than likely right
that at least these subtle clues in the
background are connected to each other
right yeah and this seems like again the
the realm and the characters with which
to maybe address some of those things as
they are
dealing with the realm of gods directly
well [ __ ] all right guys
the hell of a video thank you eric voss
for putting this one together on the
team at new rock stars it's videos like
this one that make me feel like a total
idiot me too every video makes me feel
like an idiot no no no no no i need to
read up on norse mythology yes i am
behind absolutely just go watch the hit
film the northmen i just think that
thor is one of the i read the mighty
thor um run but i'm i get so daunted by
it because i'm like oh there's so much
mythology there's like a whole new thing
yeah and it could be intimidating but
i'll be diving in a little bit more
before this movie comes out guys
subscribe to new rockstars thank you so
much for being here
we're not coy
nope
[Music]